it's time for the ultimate reboot
batman's versus spider-man's story Tobey
Maguire Andrew Garfield Tom Holland
Michael Kiki val kilmer George Clooney
Christian Bale Ben Affleck Lego Batman
no Chris O'Donnell and CGI'd Adam West
no nipples next to no nipples a hint of
nipples hey where'd the nipples go and I
kind of miss the nipples with a special
appearance by peak ranger Amy Jo Johnson
Patricia jangly memory Vernon Alison
McInnes Erin Cahill Alicia Perez in GDS
wrote a monk to me or Erica Fong
Christina Masterson Camille hide and
Naomi Scott and drama placement by the
1981 Magritte
[Applause]
2200 2005 degree of 2010 Magrib 2012
McRib 2014 matron and the 2016 Maghreb
Willard Scott George Voorhees King Jack
deputy David Hussey John Wharton Roger
says Olinsky Bradley Rickson Francis X
Goodrich and Brad Lennon and don't
forget to enjoy this movie with the help
of these zona generics Zoli so said
zoltron dazzling medicine I'm sponsored
a circuit and so products
Batman's vs. spider-man's
[Applause]
you